you're about to enjoy a free preview of
free guy
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this
is free city
look at this guy
he's one of the sunglasses people
and the people who wear sunglasses
are heroes
they have a devil may care attitude and
they run this town
oh i know
see
that's not even his car
or his wife
for the sunglasses people they get to do
anything they want they go on all sorts
of missions they got cool hair cool
clothes
i mean the laws aren't really lost to
them they're more like
mild suggestions
like i don't think he's gonna return
that car
or that nice lady
[Music]
see what i mean
hero
[Applause]
my name is guy
and i live
in paradise
i've lived here in free city my whole
life i've got a best friend i've got a
goldfish and i work at the bank what
more could a guy want sunday should be
warm and sunny just a scattering of
drive-bys great day for the beach but
not hitman's beach which will be mined
and sprayed with high caliber fire from
a renegade gunship stolen by and every
morning i start my day with the most
delicious coffee in the whole wide whole
world medium coffee cream two sugars
that is unexpectedly hot
geez that's good it's like losing my
virginity but in my mouth
thank you for making this with such love
you're welcome
officer johnny have a good one guy don't
have a good day
have a great day
hold the fudge you mean to tell me that
nobody snapped up those bad boys today's
the day like every other day i'll be
back for those
oh so close
this is the greatest cup of coffee of
all time i want to write a song about it
i want to dance to that song it's my
body i love my life it's about finding a
lane and just staying in it that's why
they call them comfort zones they're so
damn comfortable
oh mondays am i right joe you said it
guy
[Music]
in free city
i have everything i need don't have a
good day
have a great day
thank you except
one thing
seem happy oh come on don't worry about
that guy you gonna find someone that's
okay bud
i feel like i've been looking for her
forever you know maybe it's just
maybe it's not meant to be
i know the woman i'm looking for let me
guess the one with the awful beast to
see him and upset she would feel good
yes that's her she's running space in my
brain and she won't move out and you
know what i don't want her to well guess
what she won't move either in or out you
know why because she doesn't exist she's
just a fantasy it's a fantasy
nobody try to be a hero this will all be
over soon
so how about it beers on the beach after
work of course we're going for beers on
the beach afterwards
that makes me so happy
[Music]
what have you got proof of a secret
level that's what you're looking for
right you got a video or a screen grab
nope but i know who does want to know
what i do to people who waste my time oh
wow someone wants to play hey you really
british or is that an accent filter
cause maybe we could meet up later i
don't have a burning desire to see your
mom's basement thanks
got jokes huh i've got a map shows the
location of your stash house i don't
know how you'll get him but if you do
clip 56 might interest you
oh i got a question
what's so special about this video clip
anyway what's special is i kill people
who ask questions about it
i seem fun yeah that's fine
yeah girl you're so feisty
seriously is it lewd or is that just the
experience
those are questions
did you see the sneakers on that last
robber the 2 30 no the 4 o'clock
the three-quarter high-top gorgeous foam
soles i could barely feel it when you
stepped on my face
wow life in the big city ain't nothing
like it
looks like rain
has anyone seen my hats
i mean you put it on there
[Music]
that's a new one
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
that's her
who
that's the dream girl buddy
she exists
i'm i'm gonna go talk to her
she's wearing sunglasses
so
you mean so
so people with sunglasses don't talk to
people like that you know that i gotta
try look god
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
free guy rated pg-13